Barristan the bode they call me to my
face I know what they say behind my back
Barristan me old then it's true I am old
with hair as white as all the winters
I've seen the older a man grows the less
sleep he needs these days I barely sleep
at all when darkness falls over this
strange city
I find myself visited by the faces of
the kings I have served the faces of
those I swore to protect the faces of
those I failed all I ever wanted was to
live a life of honor defending a king
worthy of service during the war the
ninepenny kings I sought out maelys the
monstrous last of the Blackfyre
pretenders who had started this whole
war maelys believed that his Targaryen
blood too gave him a claim to the Iron
Throne
I made sure his blood to claim nothing
more than the dirt around his course to
show his gratitude the king elevated me
to his Kingsguard it was a proudest
moment of my life
but that King died and I wasn't with him
not that I could have saved him if I had
been but still I vowed to do better with
his son the young Prince
Aerys for 20 years his reign was
peaceful and prosperous Aerys was
well-loved by his subjects and respected
by his Lords but as years went on
Harry's temper soured he became obsessed
with dragons and fire and the swords of
the Kingsguard couldn't defend him from
the enemies he saw lurking in every
shadow my king went mad but there was
hope his son and heir Prince Rhaegar was
everything a kingdom could hope for in a
ruler he was strong but gentle wise and
cautious and a good friend
no matter the wounds Aerys dug into the
realm we had faith that his son would
sew it back together again when he
ascended the throne
then came Lord whence tourney at
Harrenhal the largest ever in Westeros I
unhorsed every man against me until only
Prince Rhaegar remained we each set our
feet in our severals and lowered our
Lancers and charged hell I fell muddy
and bruised our then watched Rhaegar
present Lyanna stark with the victors
crown of roses though she was betrothed
to Robert Baratheon and Rhaegar himself
was married to Elia Martell we all know
what happened after if I'd been a bit
quicker with my Lance if I'd chosen a
faster horse perhaps I could have spared
the kingdom from the destruction that
came after all if I'd thought to warn
Brandon stark against his rashness he
came to King's Landing himself demanding
Rhaegar return his sister poor fool if
he'd only known the depth of Aerys
madness he wouldn't have dared provoke
him
Ares ordered Brandon imprisoned and I
could do nothing but obey when Brandon's
father Lord Rickard stark came to King's
Landing to beg for his son Aerys burned
him alive
but I could do nothing but watch I had
sworn a vow to a Mad King and was honor
abound to obey Him even at the cost of
my soul Ravens soon arrived with dark
news for the king the Vale was an open
revolt demanding lyanna stark's return
Robert Baratheon was smashing any army
that dared face him Eddard Stark
Brandon's younger brother was marching
the whole of the north down the neck and
had taken Catelyn Tully
Brandon's betrothed for his own thus
winning the support of the Riverlands
the king sent Ravens to Casterly Rock to
beg his former hand Tywin Lannister for
help and no Ravens return a plan was
devised Prince Rhaegar would personally
lead the royal forces now reinforced
with 10,000 Dornishmen north to face
Robert of the Kingsguard Lou and Mattel
and I would ride with the Prince before
we left the prince confided in me that
when he returned from this battle there
would be a great many changes in court
despite my vows to the king
I confess I was excited on the march to
face Roberts army we were sure we'd win
we had superior numbers and we had
Prince Rhaegar his presence lifted the
spirits of our men and he looked every
inch the king he was destined to become
but at the Trident the guards played a
cruel joke
Robert proved the Baratheon words as his
army smashed through our lines Lu and
Martel was killed I fell in combat badly
wounded and could do nothing but watch
as Roberts Warhammer ended Rhaegar
glorious reign before he began and the
kingdom that would never be washed away
down the Trident with his life blocked
when Robert spared me insisting his
personal mace to tend to my wounds out
of respect but respect for what my
Kingsguard shouldn't survive one came
let alone two and one who should have
been I swore an oath to House Targaryen
and I failed them all that's left of
their fire is a single ember halfway
across the world surrounded by darkness
the gods were good I would still be
young in the fullness of strength for
whatever the cost I will not let this
ember go out this time I will not fail